today's new member of the day is Richard
Dumont ei Richard thank you so much for
being a david pakman show member we do
depend directly not in some indirect
vague or amorphous sense we depend
directly on the support of members like
Richard and I encourage you to sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership
long list of member benefits you can get
you can also make a pledge at patreon by
going to patreon.com slash david pakman
show let's go to the phone lines which
are very very busy already we are going
to start with our first caller maybe
from here in the Boston area going to a
caller from the six one seven area code
caller
tell us your name where you're calling
from and you can jump right into your
topic Oh could you give me we can hear
you fine yeah okay good I just want to
make sure just of there was a lot of
static um my name is Kerry I'm from
Newton Massachusetts I called about a
few months ago at with a question about
justice Democrats and all that I really
like your answer you gave and today I
just wanted to call since especially
with the John a saw loss yesterday
it seems like the Democrats just seem to
be liked by especially on the national
level just really seem to not understand
their constituency and especially now
that with talks about 2018 and 2020 and
all that do I just figured like you know
it looks like the Democrats are going to
really need someone to look like look as
their role model and you know everyone
starts out like Bernie Sanders but I've
just been curious about kind of like
what you think about full-si gathered
and all that person talk about no like
really do Asaf thing first okay so out
of curiosity do you know in the last
many elections in Georgia sixth District
do you know roughly how much of the vote
the Democratic challenger received in
that district usually about 40% to the
bustling all it's about 33% they were
they were typically losing to tom price
by about two to one do you know what
percentage of the vote john Asaf
received in that race
48 48 percent right so I do agree with
you and I've been talking
for a while Terry that Democrats need
more for 2018 and 2020 than just were
not Trump because that could backfire in
three or four different ways which I've
outlined however I don't think that the
Georgia six district lost and I talked
about this on the show when it happened
I don't think it's as bad as some people
are pointing out because Asaf actually
got a record share of the vote for a
Democrat and I think a lot of people
don't realize that this was just an
upside-down red district that Tom Price
was just crushing in for years and years
so that's one aspect Pat I'm not saying
Terry's wrong like yeah yeah Democrats
need a progressive leader there's
questions about what's going to be the
platform but the Asaf thing is not the
end of the world I think there were two
valid ways to look at it and certainly
if a soft one that would have been a
huge win and a huge upset but you have
to remember that this is a ruby red
district used to be represented by Newt
Gingrich nice rich suburbs so you know
it's going to be in Republican control
for two more years
yeah so Terry I mean yeah I agree with
you and I've been talking about it I'm
gonna continue talking about it but I
would not freak out about the Asaf loss
yeah I mean personally like I wasn't too
excited for awesome just that I really
found handle to be I don't even know
what to say I know that um this the
humanists reported a really big segment
on how handles like out of touch stance
on the whether we should have a liveable
minimum wage yeah you know it isn't that
funny but it's like I'd stop the end of
the world
yeah yeah but personally I'm like hoping
like if - yeah especially with like cozy
gabbard's
kind of rising rising up in the ranks
and all that do that there's at least
some way we could like diversify the the
progressive camps leadership because I
think right now I'm once I talking about
Elizabeth Warren at Bernie Sanders and
especially by like capitalizing on those
students that problem we have is a
they're kind of a little bit older and B
especially since like they attract a lot
of Millennials like it's very important
to have like more like younger leaders
and all that and I think awesome may
have helped in that regard but like I do
think that you know just saying like
Bernie 2020 or war 2020 is a good at
I got to Terry alright thanks very much
appreciate the call a very very good
point and point well made